le parc fonctionne nature qui a rouvert
ses portes ce week end après sa
traditionnelle coupure hivernale le
public a pu re découvrir les monuments
français mais aussi les dernières
attractions comme la grotte et le champ
de fouilles cette réouverture était
aussi l'occasion pour le parc de
proposer de nouvelles animations on
écoute les premiers visiteurs
c'est plutôt sympa déjà l'ensemble des
des monuments c'est intéressant et puis
la partie attraction là qui est superbe
que pour les enfants en plus on a la
chance on a le soleil donc ses grands il
ya beaucoup d' espaces il ya plein
d'autres actions le détail puis le
moment le voyage ont fait le voyage
partout en france sans y est allé c'est
vraiment extraordinaire iliad est
vraiment des points de détails sur les
monuments c'est les commentaires peu
intéressants aussi pour pouvoir s'y
retrouver